ciao ragazzi benvenuti ad una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi farò una
sfida di cucina con un rappresentante di
un canale enorme sono dei nostri amici
ma oggi mela collo di batterli in cucina
anche se tendenzialmente ci battono ogni
giorno giallo zafferano come c'è manuela
allora manuel panel io sono stato ospite
tuo e da cucina lo zafferano è stato uno
e momenti più belli della mia vita è
arrivato il momento di farti vivere uno
dei più brutti che cosa facciamo oggi
giallo zafferano e cucina buttata gz e
cibi dumas si sfidano prevalente avremo
degli ingredienti che non so niente tu
non sai niente così mi hanno detto per
cui dovremo batterci e fare il piatto
più buono a giudicarlo ci sarà da una
parte la giuria di giallo zafferano che
qui presenti dall'altra parte quella di
cucina buttata non so quale delle due
sia più di parte né mi
prendi il tuo cestino o picnic il
verrebbe da dire
quando un ares i il lento prima cercato
di guardare ho visto solo una cosa di
apri un gioco e riconosce gli
ingredienti elenchiamo gli ingredienti
della nostra sfida noi dovremo
utilizzare all'interno di una certa
mister forum funghi farina pomodori
alloro stones e guanciale carne di
vitella tutto dobbiamo usare tutto tutto
tutto
hai già qualche idea che ti frulla ma tu
già ti sta venendo un idea no potrei fa
una roba che mi mi metti in un cul de
sac mai allora vado drink alla fine cioè
se non lo perché adesso
infatti soggetto anche otto ore e 30
minuti bravissimo cerca di dormire anche
durante la belle ha preparato piatto e
facciamola statico la di merda dai
mister mi sta distraendo stessi fare un
nostro fan due anche i cazzi tuoi inizia
la sfida
[Musica]
ios caldo già al forno però noto mi sta
mettendo l'ansia opere pie vento ti
prego allora io parto dalle [ __ ]
granchio parto dalle tante valori che
questo qui un regalo molto bello a me
caro faty brutto
muso solo quelle fatte allora qua si sta
scaldando si salta la luce
sarei ritornato
scusa questa qui la patata ma dove spero
il mio appartamento eccole qua allora io
voglio fare sicuramente un po cosa
accadendo perché almeno so che non si
sforma non so nemmeno che cosa sto
facendo un antipasto un secondo un primo
non ho idea to crea invece scusami che
in che direzione sta andando e sta
andando direzione streetfood patatine al
forno con tutto quello che avete di
aromi qualche usarla all'opera una loro
l'odio io sento già il sapore della
sconfitta devo farmi venire un'idea
un'idea che sprechi io intanto faccio a
ora che mossa o e ti schizzo pure un
pochino l'argomento cercando di
rovinarti spariamo pò d'olio rimasta bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
poi in forno e tra 5 minuti alla ricetta
pronta guarda che tocco e hai usato dall
oro giusto anzi guarda qua
eccolo qua la loro l'ho usato
fisico abbiamo esagerato però la
macchina indicazione del tumulto piatto
nel milieu gianmarco però più vado
avanti e più forse qualcosa si fuori
nella mia è qui che si vede l'artista io
dico tu hai lì il tuo piatto di merda
aggiungo pure a me stai buttando la tua
roba già un tagliere grosso così certo
guarda nell'evento adesso mettendo le
cose
motivo si sta creando una idea faccio
degli gnocchi ma li faccio come non li
avete mai visti prima d'ora
ora come detto il polo in padella
da qua a qualche bravo e stanley con le
mani ora come metto i funghi ha mai
fatto meglio di così ma continui a
permettere questa mossa pensando che sia
chissà quale
dio bello
quando la cucina mi diventa poesia
ornato cercarmi rischia e quasi quasi
bruciato il porno no quasi bruciato
varrà è tutto nero che voglia di
metterci i [ __ ] dentro che guarda è
partito sapere che cosa state facendo
perché c'è
come si chiama il tuo piatto orgia
streetfood ok il mio invece è un fiocco
decomposto fida del composto
di strutturato
come la taglia piano piano sembra sempre
una critica da parte tu no no no anzi il
tuo complimento sembra un calcio in culo
tu che stai facendo scusami non e
palline che si trasformeranno in delle
pitt e
ci sono delle forbici apre così toglie
il tessuto connettivo non sapevo in che
modo tritarla sembrava non farlo in
fieri che guardate di vita
[Risate]
è una persona magari poi un dividendo
perché invece lui qua non ci ha messo
niente
ti rendi conto che da mezz'ora che fai
la stessa gag di questo che finisca io
potevo impiattare allevatori mattina io
non posso più poggiare niente qua perché
c'è solo farina allora ragazzi sto per
fare un pezzo di funghi per fare un po
da collante è strato capito fondo
leggero e cui le hanno seguite dalla sua
crema di funghi sotto ogni stampino poi
prendiamo quindi la criminal 8 da questa
nota serve per attaccarli è una sorta di
burro naturale anche perché non c'era il
burro non c'e ragazze non so se ti sei
reso conto che toccò la mano sinistra
tiene sempre così si è paralizzato dalla
paura
questo è stato uno dei muffin ma fin li
ion occhi di muffin
scorrette di muffin tutti quanti
una preghiera
so che non sono proprio il primo dei
fedeli
però se ti capitasse un miracolo
adesso
questa qui sarà una stronza
bambino le parole di marco sa giocare
con le vite di mano e popolari dei man
vagliati acari non era peccato un po di
maionese essere vera
fischia che tu fai sti fagottini ripieni
di merda penso al mio e ognuno pensa al
suo
sembra un'astronave non pensare se si
vede sempre uno stronzo
e questo un gran tocco
com'è il nome di questo piatto vita
buttata patate croccanti abitanti e
peeta con vitello saltato al profumo di
porno e funghi ma con pomodorini
primaverili volessimo i miei si chiamano
gli occhi serra mascelle vignocchi serra
mascelle sono fatti con un ragù fresco
con funghi e vitella impreziositi con
pesto di funghi e
guanciale la loro caratteristica che una
volta mi mette in bocca
noi tiri mai più fuori non c'è non poche
ombre null fine è finita alla tua
partiamo con la vita buttata cercherò di
non aggiungere
fino a buttava
tua
lineare
detto
si accompagnano con le patate sai qual è
la cosa che sento i più profumati alloro
proprio è l'ingrediente principe è
arrivato il momento di presentare il mio
piatto
ma ti sei ispirata qualche artista della
siciliano e l'urlo di munch il
presidente queste sei interazione bruto
e trasmetterlo all'interno questo piatto
gnocco sanremo ascelle saggiamo
manca sale però è una roba mia lui ho
talmente pensare subito a restare o no
tav e pomodorini non c'entra un cazzo
nel senso troppo sono andati troppo per
me non mi stai sulla punta di quelli che
questo qui era se come una merda
la sua vita l'atomica ora c'è bocca un
cammello era veramente gradevole date
volino vabbè
giocare così e adesso lasciamo entrare i
giudici va bene superarle scura ti vedo
un po aiuti siamo pronti
di cosa ha paura martin non lo so di
cosa devo avere paura
occhio come rispondi non partiamo da
vita puntata è così almeno disseccate un
po la bocca e dopo la mandate con le
mani perché
mandi via libera giusta bravo dove meter
bene figurate se mi faccio parla dietro
vado a
lui è
attiva la carne
certo perché non voleva che fosse troppo
aggressivo ieri sera sento fortissima
ragazze perché volevo che avesse una
bella presenza
allora ragazzi posso dire una cosa dici
io sono il padrone di casa va bene
va bene solo grazie va bene un passo
indietro e secondo me dico che il
vincitore di questa puntata è l'amicizia
[Musica]
cioè se dovessi scegliere un vincitore
comunque nel senso tra questi due
canzoni non so come dire me prendere una
radice prendi in mano una roba più buona
esatto un giovane
io automaticamente di capisco che pur di
fare qualità per la qualità è vero
nell'amicizia vino se andate a finire
sono tanti ragazzi fatevi un giro su
giallo zafferano anche se ce l'avete già
fatti certo come minimo un bacio ciao
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]